hi everyone thanks for sticking around
to the end of the conference my name is
Liz sander and I'm going to be talking
about evolutionary algorithms and how we
can use them to perfect the art of good
enough finding good enough solutions for
difficult problems so let's say that you
let's say that you work for a UPS or
USPS yeah okay let's say you work for US
PS and you have a lot of stops you need
to make and a lot of deliveries you need
to make so how do you decide what route
to take or how to assign people to go
along a route this is actually a really
difficult problem if you have 60 or more
stops then there are more possible
routes than there are atoms in the
universe so clearly we need some way of
like distinguishing between these all
these possible routes another case that
is relevant to my biologist friends is
um you work with zebrafish someone needs
to take care of the zebrafish and
everyone has different scheduling
constraints and so you need to figure
out how do you schedule people and meet
all the constraints so that zebrafish
get taken care of and you have as few
complex as possible this is also a
really challenging problem and finally a
case that's near and dear to my heart um
so in Skyrim this is a screenshot from
the game Skyrim you have a maximum carry
weight and every item has a weight and a
value so what you can sell it for and so
if you're in a dungeon there's way more
stuff than you can pick up then you can
keep with you so you need to decide what
you keep so you don't want to spend all
of your time like working out the exact
optimal solution right you want to like
you want to get back to town so you can
sell your stuff and give sweet house and
Whiterun um so we need to find some way
of distinguishing between these all
these solutions which we can't possibly
enumerate and find something that's good
enough so that we can just pick
something and move on right so sometimes
we can't find the best solution there
are just too many and there's no like
simple way to find the absolute best but
most the time we don't need to write we
just need to find something that's good
enough for our purposes so let's focus
on finding an answer that's good enough
and so this is where evolutionary
algorithms comes in well so I kind of
lied in my talk title a little bit I am
going to talk about evolutionary
algorithms but I'm gonna talk more
generally about heuristic optimizers
with a random component um so I could
have put that in my title instead but
this is a really boring name and
probably none of you would have come to
my talk um so I'm just gonna break down
some of the jargon that's in this name
so heuristic just means like a rule of
thumb right we can't guarantee that
we're gonna find the absolute best
answer we're using heuristics to do it
and optimizer means that we're
maximizing or minimizing some function
and depending on what field you're
coming from this may be called different
things so it may be called an objective
function a cost function or a fitness
function I'm gonna try to be consistent
throughout use fitness functions but
just so you know these are all like
basically equivalent when the random
component just means that it's
non-deterministic so there are heuristic
strategies like greedy solutions that
don't involve any randomness at all but
what I'm gonna focus on today are our
solutions our algorithms where you're
making some changes based on randomness
where you're initializing solutions
based on randomness so why are we using
new turistic algorithms there are
methods out there right that guarantee
that we find the true optimal solution
if you meet the assumptions so gradient
descent is a really common optimizer but
it makes a lot of assumptions right you
have to have a convex function it needs
to be differentiable and there are a lot
of really difficult but important
problems out there that we need to solve
that don't meet these don't meet these
assumptions so if you have just a
function like this and this is a pretty
simple case right this is a
one-dimensional problem so like X would
just be some like variable that you're
trying to optimize over and Y is the
values like the fitness value because
this has multiple peaks and basins this
is something that your gradient descent
is
guaranteed to find the optimal solution
for things get even worse if you have a
like a fitness landscape or like a
fitness function that is discrete so if
your inputs to the function are discrete
like a vector of ones and zeros
it's obviously not differentiable so but
you still want to solve this problem so
what do these optimization functions
look like a lot of times they're pretty
high dimensional so they have a lot of
inputs and one output so in the Skyrim
leading example which if you're familiar
um it's basically the knapsack problem
it's like just a fun version of the app
type problem um so that has a lot of
inputs you have all the possible items
you could put in your inventory um and
one output which is the value of
everything that you're carrying so when
it's high dimensional it means there's a
lot of possible solutions and so we need
some way to search through all those
another common feature or feature that
we'd like for these objective functions
is that nearby solutions are of similar
quality so if you look at this function
here um there are some big jumps where
if you change X a little bit you get a
big change in the fitness but for the
most part if you make a small change
it's gonna make a fairly small
difference in the fitness function and
this is really important because we need
to traverse this space somehow if it's
just a completely random landscape
there's really no point doing any
searching we may as well just either
generate a bunch of random solutions or
just take one and go with it and so just
to brown this optimization function in
like the examples that I gave this usps
case which is basically the Traveling
Salesman problem what you're trying to
do is minimize distance for the
scheduling problem which is basically
related to the nurse scheduling problem
you're trying to minimize conflicts and
for the Skyrim leading problem you're
trying to maximize the value so here's
an example of what a realistic fitness
function might look like this is only
two dimensions but you can see like it's
all these solutions are discrete you
have multiple local optima so this is
like a peak it looks pretty promising
but
true optimum is actually over here so
it's pretty complex and it's hard to
traverse and it's hard to know exactly
how to traverse it and you're probably
not gonna know exactly what your fitness
function looks like so ideally we would
like to find this global maximum but if
we find something that's not exactly the
best solution we might be able to get by
with this so here's an example of a
fitness function I'm gonna be using the
knapsack problem the Skyrim looting
problem throughout for my code examples
so at the top I just have some example
inputs so the solution is going to be a
vector of ones and zeros which is
basically we have five items and then a
1 means we're putting it in the
inventory and a zero means we're
excluding it each of those things has a
weight which are fixed for those items
it has a specific values like a cell
value that's also fixed and then we have
a maximum weight that we can carry and
then for the fitness function it takes
in all of those things so the knapsack
is the solution here
I'm just doing this in a very like
simple basic way where you start with 0
and then you iterate over all the items
in the solution if it's present in your
candidate solution then you add the
weight and the value of that item and
then we want to check do we need the
constraints right if the total weight is
higher than the maximum weight that we
can carry this has value zero to us
right um you can do other things like
apply a penalty for going over weight um
but this is just like the simplest case
of a fitness function and so if we don't
if we do meet that constraint then we
want to return the total value so first
I'm gonna start off with a very simple
version of one of these heuristic
optimizers with a random component and
that's a hill climber so let's say we
have a really simple fitness function
that we can that's pretty easy to
traverse this is continuous there's only
one peak so that's cool um first we want
to randomly initialize a solution and so
I've just started right there then I'm
going to apply a mutation and that means
I'm just going to make a small change to
that solution and move nearby so here
I'm making a small change and so this is
my candidate solution right
this is where I started if that
candidate solution is better than we
accept it if it's worse then we always
reject it and so basically this was just
a local optimization it's climbing this
hill and so as if you like have that
solution that's better than if you
accept it and you keep moving like this
until you reach the top of whatever peak
you started near basically so what are
the properties of this it gets stuck in
local optima a lot obviously it's a
local optimizer but it's really fast
it's so simple you're basically just
generating solutions you just accept
whatever is better and so it requires
basically no tuning there are really no
parameters to change there except how
you're mutating the solution and that
means it can actually be a really good
solution to some problems it's so fast
that you can just start it a bunch of
times and hopefully you'll start near
the true global optimum at one point and
you'll find that hell oh that's that's
the wrong title um but yeah if you have
a more complicated function like this
then it's not gonna do quite as well but
maybe if you started a bunch of times
you'll be able to find that peak so
here's I'm just going to give you a code
example for the hill climber because
it's the simplest of the ones that I'm
going to look at um I'm not actually
gonna go through a full code example for
each of these but I do have like a
github repository that has code examples
for everything that I'm talking about
so to initialize the Skyrim looting
problem I'm just taking in the number of
items in the knapsack and then I'm just
creating basically I'm just
pre-allocated a list of zeros and then
iterating one by one and basically just
flipping a coin as to whether I add it
or not
so this is kind of a dumb way to
initialize the knapsack but you know it
can work and as a simple mutation
function all I'm doing is just flipping
one bit so basically that means I'm
gonna randomly select an item and if it
is in the inventory I'm gonna remove it
if it's not in the inventory that I'm
gonna add it so here I'm just doing that
by like choosing an index
in the list and then swapping it and
finally the hillclimber itself so you
can see this is not that much code this
is a pretty big font on this slide and
it all fits these algorithms actually
don't really take that many lines of
code to write so here what I'm doing is
I'm taking in a number of steps so
that's how many times I'm trying to
generate a new solution the weights and
values that those are the fixed
parameters of the problem that I
mentioned before the maximum weight that
you can carry and a random seed for
reproducibility so first I'm going to
initialize my solution um then I'm gonna
calculate the fitness of it and then for
each step I'm going to make a small
change and that's my candidate solution
and then I'm just gonna compare the
Fitness's of those two and then I repeat
that for however many steps I'm running
it and return the best so the next one I
want to talk about is simulated
annealing this is actually pretty
similar to hill climbing but it has a
changing temperature so what does that
mean the temperature is essentially a
probability of accepting a bad step and
this is kind of based on the idea that
molecules at a hotter temperature tend
to move around more randomly whereas at
a colder temperature they're less likely
to move around and they'll only move
into a more stable configuration so at a
hot temperature we'll accept a lot of
bad steps and it's essentially a random
walk we'll make some change and we'll
just say yeah sure let's try that um at
a colder temperature it's more like a
hill climber you're not accepting as
many bad steps so you have this kind of
continuum at very hot temperatures it's
a random walk at very cold temperatures
it's a hill climber and the idea is that
you start at a fairly hot temperature to
explore the fitness landscape and over
time you're cooling the temperature and
so you're like honing in more and more
on promising areas of the fitness
landscape and so at the beginning if
this is your fitness function you could
have so it's just like a hill climber
where you only have one solution at a
time but in the early steps you're going
to be all over the place you're just
trying to
explore this whole landscape and find
promising areas as the temperature cools
down and you run it for longer you're
going to be honing in on these Peaks and
hopefully by the time you cooled it and
you're finished running the algorithm
you're fairly close to the optimum
solution although it's possible that
you'll still get stuck in a little
optimum so this is great because it
gives us both exploration and
exploitation
so exploration is traversing the fitness
landscape trying to find promising areas
and exploitation is working in a region
where you already have been and trying
to find the absolute best solution in
that region this is still really fast
because you only have one solution at a
time and really all the only overhead
you're adding is keeping track of the
temperature but there is more tuning so
there are cooling schedules you have to
figure out like how hot the temperature
you're starting at how cold you end it
how you change that temperature over
time you can potentially reheat it there
are lots of variants and there's like a
whole little cottage industry of people
writing papers about simulated annealing
and the best cooling schedules under
different conditions and for specific
problems probably your so your problem
doesn't fit exactly into one of these
very constrained problems that a paper
has been written about um that's why our
using one of these like random based
optimizers but yeah there is there's a
lot of tuning involved and so I just
wanted to get note about tuning which is
a it's hard you don't really know that
much about your fitness landscape so
it's hard to know a priori what is a
good cooling schedule or what's a good
mutation rate um so a reasonable way to
handle this is to do a grid search you
just have a few different things you
want to try out for each parameter that
you're tuning and then you try each
combination of those so this is kind of
unfortunate this is actually like one of
the more difficult parts of these
algorithms because the structure the
algorithms themselves is fairly simple
so that's just kind of how it is so
finally I
evolutionary algorithms was in the title
so now I'm gonna talk about that what
I'm talking about right now is basically
a genetic algorithm but the structure is
generally the same across different
evolutionary algorithms so what makes
evolutionary algorithms different from
these other strategies is that you have
a population of solutions um so you're
probably keeping these in some kind of
list so here here's your population each
of these squares represents a solution
and let's say that the optimum is like a
warm color so we're trying to select
warmer colored solutions so first
there's a selection step um so you go
from this population and you want to
choose an individual to be a parent so
the basic flow of this algorithm is
you're going to replace this population
with child populate with a population of
children um which are closely related to
the parent population and you're just
going to evolve the whole population
through time kind of following this
biological idea of evolution like slow
gradual change of a population through
time so what does the selection look
like um a really good selection
algorithm is tournament selection and
this is really simple basically you just
choose some number of candidates I
personally recommend too and the best of
those candidates becomes a parent so
just to give you a sense of what the
inputs look like the fit fits is a list
of Fitness's that are associated with
like a list of solutions say and here
I'm setting the tournament size to be 2
so it's just the number of candidates in
the tournament and basically I'm gonna
sample from all of the different from
all those different Fitness's and those
are my competitors then I'm gonna get
their Fitness's and whichever one has
the maximum so I'm treating this as a
maximization problem is the winner and I
return that index and so then I'm gonna
take that parent solution and I'm gonna
mutate it or recombine it to create a
child and so you can see it's gonna be
fairly similar
to the parent but you can see it has a
slightly different fitness because we've
changed it a little bit so mutation I've
already talked about recombination is a
little bit more complicated the idea is
that you take multiple parents and you
take aspects of each of those solutions
so you might take the whatever the first
parent has like the first three items
and then the second three items from the
next parent and then the third step is
repopulation so you repeat these first
two steps once for every individual in
the population until you've completely
replaced the parent population and
that's one step so you can see if this
was the parent population before maybe
in the next generation it looks a little
bit more homogeneous because the better
solutions have been chosen more times
and so they are the parents for more of
the child solution in the next step and
then over time the population as a whole
is going to start off exploring
different areas in the fitness landscape
and over time it's going to converge to
the most promising areas and exploit
those areas so there's some major
advantages to this first off you're
unlikely to get stuck in a single local
optimum because you're automatically
exploring a lot of areas at once I also
think this connection to biology is just
really cool and kind of appealing but
there are some disadvantages too so it
could be easy to lose variation quickly
if your selection is too strong there's
also more tuning involved so you have to
choose a selection function you have to
choose a mutation function and a
recombination function you have to
choose the selection strength the
population size mutation size and all of
these things can have either very small
or very large effect on the quality of
your final output and it's hard to know
in advance what's gonna have a large
effect although I found a lot of times
like how you're mutating has a really
huge effect on the quality of the
solution so this is probably something
to spend a little bit more time tuning
so you can also see this algorithm is
going to be a lot slower than a hill
climber right you have to maintain an
entire population and you have to
Fitness is a lot you're you have this
whole process for a selection and then
you have to mutate you have to keep
track of a lot it's also more memory
hungry because you're maintaining all
these solutions in memory and so if each
solution takes up a lot of space and
have a large population size this can
slow things down more it can create its
own problems but overall these have the
potential to be really powerful and to
explore a lot more than the algorithms
that have only a single solution at once
so just to kind of summarize all these
algorithms hillclimber is really fast
but it gets stuck easily the simulated
annealing is also pretty fast and it can
explore better and evolutionary
algorithms are generally slow and memory
hungry but potentially really powerful I
also want to give honorable mention to
an algorithm I didn't really have time
to talk about in detail which is
metropolis coupled Markov chain Monte
Carlo or MC cubed and if you're familiar
with Markov chain Monte Carlo you can
you can use it for calculating
posteriors but you can also use it as an
optimization algorithm
it's basically simulated annealing with
a constant temperature um so in MC cubed
you're running several parallel searches
at different constant temperatures so
you have some chains running at very hot
temperatures and some that cold
temperatures and then every so often you
give them the chance to swap around so
if the chain running at a hotter
temperature find something promising
then you cool it off and let it exploit
that region more this is really cool and
it often works really well but there are
some complications with implementing it
so this is my general overview to these
different kinds of algorithms so for if
this is something that you're interested
in there are a lot of papers and books
on optimization I don't know of a single
like resource that has all this
information because it's actually coming
from a lot of different fields a lot of
these were developed sort of
independently of each other and you have
to kind of hunt around to find them all
but for discrete problems the term you
probably want to look up is
combinatorial optimization um so there
are other evolutionary algorithms I
didn't
get a chance to mention but that are
really cool differential evolution
evolutionary strategies which is similar
to genetic algorithms but for like
floating point values and like
continuous values instead of discrete
ones genetic programming which lets you
evolve functions and Alps or age layered
population structure which is like
another complication you can add on to
these like population based methods so I
also wanted to talk a little bit so the
examples I gave we're kind of like goofy
toy examples but um like right now I'm
working on my PhD and I wouldn't have
much of a dissertation without these
algorithms they're really useful for a
lot of problems they're really useful
for hard problems where you don't really
know where to start in solving them and
so I used them to try to generate stable
food webs and my backgrounds in ecology
and I've also used them to try to
identify like similar groups of species
so like parasites or top predators in
the ecological system and I'm currently
interning at civis and I'm using them
there as well for ad spending so like I
said um I have a github repository that
has worked Python examples for
hillclimber simulated annealing MC cubed
and genetic algorithms for the Traveling
Salesman problem and so this is the link
for that and then I you can also look at
my blog and my first post was actually
about this this started as a workshop
that I turned into a talk sense so
there's a little bit more detail in that
post and I don't see your question
yep so the question was do these
solutions lend themselves to a training
test data split uh and that's I'll be
sure the answer that it might kind of
depend on the problem I I would think
probably not in a lot of cases if you're
doing something like genetic programming
where what you're evolving is actually a
function then it might make sense to
train that and then test it but a lot of
times you're just taking a specific data
set and trying to find the best solution
for that data set so it doesn't
necessarily translate to a training set
test that kind of approach
right so the question was what is the
basic workflow for this do you start
writing a hill climber or do you just
skip that is it not worth it
that's a really good question I actually
usually start writing a hill climber
because the code structure is the
simplest um a lot of times I'll
prototype these in Python and then if I
need to run it for longer I'll actually
write it and Lexie or some compiled
language although depending on the size
of your problem you can get by in Python
so a lot of times I'll start with a hill
climber and then it's all of the other
algorithms are very similar in structure
so from there you can just sort of roll
up a simulated annealing the MC cubed
and genetic algorithm a lot of times I
write like at least three of those and
just try different combinations of
parameters and see where I get the best
results yep
so the question was if my implementation
of these algorithms differ from other
implementations in any meaningful way
um I guess I'm not sure exactly what you
mean like my implementation can vary a
little bit based on the data structure
that I'm working with to try to like get
the most efficiency for that data
structure um I mean the mutation
function that I showed and like the
initialization function those were like
a little simplistic I might think a
little bit more about my specific
problem and say like for the knapsack
problem I was initializing it just like
with 50% like on average you're gonna
get 50% ones and 50% zeros I might
change that a little bit to make sure I
was starting with a valid solution that
fit in my constraints so there are
things like that but in terms of the
basic structure that's that's pretty
much how it works yep
so the question was um is there an
open-source library for this or is the
problem space different enough that
usually write your own so I usually end
up writing my own part of that's because
a lot of times I end up using C in the
end so I'll use Python to figure out how
I want to handle the data structures um
there is a PI MC cubed library but I
haven't really looked into it um but in
terms of lines of code these are like
pretty fast to roll up and if you have
the structure of one you can easily like
port it to another case so I I don't
really know of any open-source libraries
for these but it isn't really a huge
burden in terms of writing the code
right right so the question is how do I
choose mutation function so a various by
problem but basically you want to make
sure that it's small enough that you're
still retaining a lot of the basic
characteristics of the parent solution
but you you want it to sometimes
improve and sometimes like not be as
good as the parent right so I probably
wouldn't choose flipping a bit for the
knapsack problem because once you kind
of run into your constraint of the
maximum weight if you anytime you try to
add anytime you try to add something to
the knapsack you're not gonna have a
valid knapsack anymore so you probably
want to like make a bigger change than
that so that you can move around a
little bit more and not get stuck in
like small valleys so it's mostly trying
to tune the size but something I would
recommend is like try a few of them like
think of what are a few different
approaches that might be the right size
are like try tuning the size of the
mutation and see how that affects it any
other questions yep so the question is
how how do you know how long to run the
NC cubed algorithm so for all of these a
lot of times what I'll do is I'll make a
convergence plot so you can just like
keep a history and just like print out
two file every say like 100 or thousand
steps um like the current best solution
and what the quality of that solution is
and generally you'll see kind of like a
decay that like it'll be sort of a
decaying function where you get a huge
benefit at first and then over time
you'll get like less and less benefit
and then you've probably gotten the best
solution you're gonna find and so if you
can run it a few times and get like
confidence intervals or like standard
errors for that that'll give you a good
sense of how long you need to run it and
that's also really helpful for pitting
these different algorithms against each
other right
you can like write one of these for each
of your algorithms and then see how
those convergence plots differ but MC
cubes has a lot of continuing variation
in it it has like this constant source
of variation from the hotter chains so
that one is likely to have a pretty slow
convergence where as a hill climber is
gonna have really fast convergence
anything else great thank you